un peu
lundi soir au nom de toute la rédaction
et de toute l'équipe d'antenne 2 qui a
préparé ce journal permettez moi de vous
souhaiter d'ores et déjà un joyeux noël
cette nuit de noël daniel monde entier
on se prépare à la vie pour le mieux
possible
tout ça parce qu'il y avait dans une
petite ville du chu les ppm aujourd'hui
en cisjordanie une famille que le monde
son premier-né l'enveloppa de l'ange
pour reprendre les paroles de
l'évangéliste luc et le coucha dans une
village que part qu'il n'y avait pas de
place à l'hôtel
quarante deux mille pèlerins venus de
l'étranger vont célébrer cette année
noël en israël centre de ce pèlerinage à
méteren une petite ville située à une
dizaine de kilomètres de jérusalem
c'est la seule ville de cisjordanie
avoir une majorité démographique
chrétienne la célébration a commencé
j'avais émis par une procession de
jérusalem une rente le sauveur jésus
mais en raison des derniers attentats
les mesures de sécurité sont plus
rigoureuses que d'habitude seuls peuvent
accéder à bethléem il n'a permis spécial
à quelques heures de noël beyrouth a
tout fait pour rejoindre est pas comme
les autres elle a tenu aussi le garde en
actions jours et demi dans ses rues dès
cet après-midi plusieurs dizaines de
libanais sont allés à jérusalem pour
participer à une prière spéciale
organisée par le comité des chrétiens
pour le vol le commandant sa balade chef
de muscle ton souffle du vent c'était
jouable
20 heures
enfin ces bronzes de tradition noël se
fête de 7 janvier une vieille histoire
de calendrier mal revue qui datent de
472 les mots ce que nico sont encore aux
achats entre voisins en fête de la
nativité du christ derniers préparatifs
dernières répétitions il y a encore du
travail d'ici le job
tiendront les mutuelles de metz et de
nancy
tous deux ont tenu à manifester leur
inquiétude devant l'aggravation du
chômage en lorraine ils ont déclaré
jeudi qu avons nous le droit de fêter
noël sets 7-6 nous femmes et les langues
oise des choses
oui si c'était noël signifie partager
des expériences de tous les hommes de
bonne volonté
monseigneur jean bernard et des voix et
monseigneur ménages l2 reims serré la
messe de minuit au milieu des
travailleurs de longue avec nous ce soir
monseigneur marty calme à paris on
continue comme en vendée comme en hausse
et un message de paix et de joie dans un
environnement qui n'est pas très rose
vous avez raison c'est tout le droit
d'intervention seigneur de metz devance
milliers de reims
car noël c'est sans doute pour nous que
tient la grande joie de noël qui
quelquefois quand on voit les wittmann
genevoise quatre jours nous mais il y à
aussi à reste toujours le noël de la
souffrance et le chômage est
certainement actuellement dans cette
crise économique la plus grave c'est ce
qu'a promis dans les familles soit
oublié qu'elles soient cadres ou des
enfants ont leur papa chômeurs je plains
les jeunes aux sirènes de la ville passe
droit mais je dois aussi important de
celui du mariage le droit au travail
c'est vraiment une épreuve blake n 6 qui
nous quelques lanceuses n'acceptons pas
certes la souffrance et nous ne fêtons
pas la souffrance mais nous fêtons 20
plus amoureux lieu qui est venu un angle
de vent pour nous aider à comprendre ce
qu'est la vie quel sens et là quel sens
à la souffrance j'avoue que pour nous
chrétiens nous envoyait un super mais la
souffrance les vaccins souffrance comme
la vie signé en ce sens à la vie
éternelle
monseigneur comment à la fin de cette
année 78 percevez-vous l'église de
france
on lui reproche souvent
tim il reproche notamment à l'épiscopat
dé beaucoup trop faible comment percevez
vous allez vivre et que nous serons à
communautés chrétiennes en france
moi j'ai très grande confiance
actuellement de france depuis l'église
de france a pris une orientation
missionnaire tarifs art car nous sommes
sereins pays ni à rendre le forum foi
chrétienne qu'il y avait autrefois nous
avons besoin dans les milieux de vie
d'être attentifs à ce qu'ils connaissent
ou 42 jours et puis aussi la france se
prévaut d'avoir toujours l'envoyer
démissionnaire dans tous les pays du
monde à l'heure actuelle il ya eu ce
sens missionnaire qui a été voulue si le
vatican
j'ai espoir que demain des missionnaires
prêtres religieuses laïques
non-refoulement selon nombreux pour
travailler en france mais ils ont encore
lui une dépêche m'apprendre gros à eco
de monseigneur lefebvre a ordonné prêtre
aujourd'hui si jeune séminariste
consignant les flammes chars de l'église
c'est une très grande tristesse pour moi
vous me l'apprenez ce soit
j'avais espoir c'est ainsi que peu
d'entre eux en ont cure et arriver à une
entente à une communion qui reviendrait
dans l'église et l'obéissance
s'il est parvenu qu'à ce soit sous fonds
pour lui je souffre aussi pour ces
jeunes qui viennent d'être ordonnées
car que vont-ils être demain en tout à
l'heure
parce que vous me nommez sérail je peux
dire et tout particulièrement pour
monseigneur à neutre et là mais qu'est
la chose un peu la plus importante que
vous allez dire dans votre message de
noël qu'est-ce qui peut retenir au je
veux surtout essayer de dire même
quelqu'un qui seront minet qui sont de
gauche
les parisiens ont cette nuit de noël
venus d'un peu partout de france et du
monde
je vais l'ordinateur que la venue de
noah c'est dieu parmi nous dieu qui est
vraiment dure toujours
mais qui est jeune qui a été vraiment au
vasseur et dia qui amène son amour et
grande preuve en est dieu qui nous
provoquent à aimer mon frère et je ferai
pas de toutes les souffrances qui leur
est fait mais est ce que d'aucuns
répondront pour traduire cet amour de
dieu aujourd'hui parce que nous savons
nous chrétiens que dieu non seulement
est parmi nous mais au final j'ajoute
que le pape jean plein de la paix
symbolique mais l'apport de tous les
romains pour leur porter le message de
noël paix aux hommes de bonne volonté
le son père a demandé aujourd'hui à
chaque foyer pour lui permettre de se
joindre à sa fête de famille avec une
pause à feurs pour ceux qui seraient
environ
la violence a repris de plus belle en
cette veille de noël teheran une
personne a été tuée cette après midi
devant l'ambassade des états unis à
machad la vision droit militaire
l'agitation a repris alors que le
gouvernement tentait de rouvrir les
universités occupées étudiants et
professeurs je voudrais une nouvelle
reine est née le grand bloc monolithique
favorable aux chats la contestation dans
l'eau si les militaires comme ont pu le
constater les uns vingtaine de en
bernard benian d'amendé
pourquoi avez vous désertez j'ai déserté
pour obéir aux ordres de mon il avait un
talent de la commune chaque déserté
parce que je veux combattre avec l'armée
au peuple pas avec celle du jeu sec à
tabriz 2000 soldats ont déserté comme
moi mais pour le moment c'est trop
dangereux de les contacter soldats que
vous venez d'entendre à 10
vent c'est un thème qu'il a déserté et
c'est vrai que tout au long des 7 août
nous avons été surpris par tout ce que
nous entendions nous pensions que
l'armée iranienne était un bloc
monolithique tout assujetti au chat
cette lame de fond de la complication
religieuse a aussi puissante armée du
moyen-orient je crois que jour après
jour il ya une espèce de prise de
conscience de la personne sont utilisés
uniquement pour ses stations pour tirer
sur la foule et que si cela continue
nous finirons par tirer sur leurs
propres vies sur leurs frères sur leur
soif
c'est une situation la super de plus
amples invente alors pourquoi si cette
prise de conscience est effective au
niveau de l'armée pourquoi
continuez-vous à tirer sur la foule
pour trois raisons la première est que
s'il ne tue pas cinq hommes qui sont
derrière si cela n'est pas suffisant il
y aura un troisième ronde soldats qui
tira sur le deuxième rang au cimetière
de behecht e zahra près de téhéran
il y à des tombes de ses soldats tués
par levasseur
pour les reconnaître le tic silhouette
maintenant sur la dalle funéraire
la deuxième raison pour laquelle l'armée
tirent sur la foule c'est que les
soldats qui participent à la lettre les
ennemis sont pas des soldats du
contingent est ce que vous voyez dans la
rue sont des rangers ont pu aux méthodes
de commando et que l'on paye en extra
820 pour vous donner il faut savoir que
l'on rentre tous une somme de 175 rials
par mois et puis la troisième raison je
crois est liée au lavage de cerveau 3 4
semaines il y avait des officiers qui
ont exclu les russes ont massé des
troupes selon la frontière que les
manifestants sont communistes
si vous n'étiez pas nous distille l'iran
sera communistes et les russes arrivent
à les aider vous savez dans très peu de
temps je finis l'armée et si par malheur
il me force à rester à rempiler
alors ma décision est prise je
déserteraient ses propos étonnants
un autre officier de l'armée iranienne
où les a également tenu mais il n'a pas
voulu le faire face à la caméra ni même
nous laisser enregistrer notre
la savane ou de méthodes d'investigation
nickel pourrais me retrouver uniquement
au timbre de ma voix voici donc la
traduction d'une partie de notre
conversation qui va d'un cimetière
endroit où 90% des jeunes officiers sont
contre la domination occidentale en iran
sont nationales
si vous voulez alors c'est vrai que la
monarchie profonde dans le pays est de
plus en plus nous pensons qu'il faut
s'en débarrasser
il faut en finir avec la corruption et
avec l'assassinât de tout un peuple
et vous parlez de tous l'entrée de m oui
mais la police politique est partout à
pied qui rend extrêmement dangereux
entre officiers et les américains vous
les voyez tous les jours
des officiers américains viennent ici
avec des salaires astronomiques les
encourage les soldats tirer sur la foule
et tué tous les manifestants
parce que je fonde était au bord de la
révolution iranienne est donc en train
de toucher peu à peu le corps le plus
chéri du régime l'armée
pour le moment la seule réponse de voir
à trouver c'est dur a cédé les vents les
militaires de carrière et dans les
casernes tous les appeler jusqu'à
présent ces kids et apporter ces femmes
et la langue grignotage les unes et les
yeux comment mesurer branlée
sérieusement cet édifice en fait le
dernier rempart du chat face à son
peuple et aussi la dialyse et de temps
avant un jour de la mort de 38 personnes
dans une ville du sud est du pays lors
des obsèques de deux enseignants de
gauche assassiné par des extrémistes de
droite
déception à bruxelles pour parler de
paix entre les joutes orales ne va
quasiment se sont achevées sans conflit
ce n'était que le premier ministre
égyptien et les ministres des affaires
étrangères dit frère des états unis se
sont contentés de dire qu'ils avaient eu
un échange de vues utile est complet et
c'est tout avec une table alain lévesque
le public pourparlers de paix en france
les primes d'assurance auto pour 2010
pour cent mais j'ai loupé par le chômage
l'idée de la fédération nationale des
assureurs reste à savoir si elle sera
suivie d'effet en tout cas c'est une
bonne idée
il révèle créteil accord ne veut pas
rater mais ils se soldent par un
tragique bilan un des trois convoyeurs
de fonds ont attaqué par des gangsters
est gravement blessé c'est un talent
armateurs a été légèrement blessé noël
c'est aussi la fête des cadeaux des bons
repas bref du commerce de ce côté là ça
ne va pas trop mal
les affaires ont paraît-il été bonne les
jouets elle se réfère le temps et
s'inspire du coup de cocktails
télévision vedette aux états unis les
joueurs intéressent le feuilleton le
héros plutôt du feuilleton vous pouvez
voir sur antenne 2 de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on n'a pas fini non plus de
règles
c'était ce soir là la grande parade de
ligue 1 là le collège carnot mineurs par
les télévisions locales
il y a toutes les vedettes des
feuilletons amérique des vedettes que
les enfants peuvent regarder le matin va
pas refaire pour les corps ou encore
dans l'économie ken qui commence très
tôt le vendredi
cette parade se dérouler le 24 novembre
au lendemain du thanksgiving day la plus
grande fête américaine
on est ainsi le coup d'envoi des fêtes
d'habas période pendant laquelle tous
les titres de consommation sont élus aux
états unis ce rayon jouets notamment du
wall street journal
après l'avenue jacques enfants
américains chevron ce vrai pour 95
dollars de cadeaux contre 90 l'an
dernier ce qui équivaut à près de 3 me
et me donnera seront parmi les jouets
depuis star noire de ses toiles les
revenus sont eux entrevaux les rêves
d'enfants
les adultes pour leur part on a
redécouvert le world games les jeux de
la guerre les américains ne se sentant
plus culpabiliser par le vide est
aujourd'hui qu'il peut rejouer à la
guerre 13 5e secondaire rouler ou pour
patton rebelles pour alexandre korda
yann et se lancer dans le wargame qu'on
appelle le quick spill dans les
académies me fait vomir 178 le ciment
qui marche très fort basé sur la mémoire
visuelle et sonore
vous jouez contre la machine qui est
longiligne et la machine sony alors que
le merlyn permet de composer des
chansons qui veut de progrès vous une
partie de poker en se faisant le jeu qui
fait fureur de la côte ouest en la
comtesse et à new york notamment fait et
pendant une semaine new york oubliant
ses soucis va redevenir la cité de
l'extravagance où l'on pourra par
exemple fêter les dernières heures de
1918 dans les restaurants mais à 600 $
le couvrante la cinquième il n'y aura
jamais vu défiler autant de touristes
étrangers que cette année car le dollar
est faible donc new york
c'est moins cher et puis les fabricants
de jouets se donneront rendez vous en
février en février où tous les supers
sur les trous dans un super nations
peuvent rejoindre pour que la fête
continue du rêve pour tous avec
l'arrivée chez nous sur les écrans
américains de super héros de la bande du
contrecoup superman l'homme qui vole et
qui résout tous les problèmes
il a les traits d'un nouvel acteur que
peluche christopher reid états unis
détourner les codes du jeu mans pour
provoquer le même succès en france
vous le saurez le 31 janvier date de
sortie du film ou plutôt non vous le
saurez dès ce soir puisque voici en
avant-première superman
m
ma peur
non
match
m
vue du mondial si ça m'a vachement de
films expriment une très grande
sexualité christopher crimes car tous
les psychologues vous diront 20 m
c'est le cloud ce volet
copé
19e
nous devons
blatt des bas
famille
nous nous inflige
vad
tél
le second
vraiment bravo chose le soir de leur vie
n'était que personne seule
sauf si c'est volontaire car cela existe
voici l'histoire d'un homme qui a choisi
de s'isoler et de sa solitude la lumière
et la plante secondes le menu il faut
une ou deux secondes
l'éternel dieu dit il n'est pas bon
j'ai 75 ans j'ai choisi de vivre seul
ici je suis un conservateur de ces
plaintes et ya une hépatite ancien du
corps et spéciaux nerfs russe en france
à 40 ans je n'aurais pas pu le faire
maintenant
20 dans ce cimetière reposent les
soldats russes qui faisait partie du
corps expéditionnaire qui était envoyé
en france
en 1916 au mois de février
car expéditionnaire des constitué de
43000 hommes de troupes et de 750
officiers dont la moitié était au fond
de visite
les seules limites mais venu ici il a il
a voulu se renseigner sur l'histoire du
pensionnaire qui lancent ces
renseignements pour son prochain livre
qui sera la suite 2 août 14 sont
nombreux personne ne vient jamais de
leur pays pour qu'on se recueillir sur
leurs tombes
alors il me semble que je remplace tous
ceux qui manquent bâtiment qui habite à
quelques centaines de mètres de haut
maintenant 23 ni de 20 secondes
je
des tendances maison je ne les bruits
très bientôt force est une question
d'organisation
c'était dur début parce que je ne savais
pas comment m'y prendre
mais avec le trajet je suis habitué 3 ce
qui difficile évidemment c'est que je
n'ai qu'une petite retraite
il faut que je fasse très attention à
mes défenses en quelque sorte je ne suis
pas un bon client pour les terribles
j'achète très peur l2 vannes mais il me
faut peu ses quelques amis qui viennent
ici des amis matin si qui va nous avons
je suis très heureux quand on vient me
visiter mais je suis très content aussi
quand le peloton seul en pointe des
ventes y pensez y
parce que on a tout le temps à faire ce
qu'on veut on n'a plus aucune contrainte
peut dire autant on a ou n'a pas d'heure
fixe on se lève quand on veut on se
couche contente quand on veut imaginer
des nuits entières
je n'ai pas qu'à rendre à personne je
sais que le lendemain matin personne ne
m'a quand je fais ce que je veux
et ça c'est le bonheur
quatrième temps il fera du bâtiment
dix secondes
je suis venu ici parce que sa prise
oralement dans paris nova qui n'en veut
se reposer guînes ici c'est le repos et
je n'ai pas le temps de m'ennuyer parce
que je vis je m'occupe du jardin et puis
j'ai une très bonne bibliothèque
j'ai beaucoup aimé la seconde femme et
ne me leblanc
je n'ai pas peur d'être malade peut-être
parce que je suis en bonne santé et il
ne faut pas peur c'est pour ça qu'on
soit ces choses là je ne vous laisse pas
franchement
matt
rien ne justifie l'absurdité du mal être
un peu le coup
un faisan
au bout du chemin je crois que j'ai
trouvé ici une sorte de paix un bonheur
tranquille
blatter cela dit beaucoup sur
l'avant-scène ce pouvoir sans l'avoir
choisie parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
famille qui sont malades ou en prison ou
démunies alors à eux nous adressons nos
voeux particuliers de noël avant de
refermer et jaune a encore trois choses
à n'était avec les véritables tiercé le
11 le seul dans l'ordre érable 1750
francs pour ses enfants et dans un ordre
différent 350 francs
les pronostics d'opérette brèche pour le
tiercé de demain demain lundi jour de ma
pelouse le 16 9 le 15 le 17 et le 18
enfin la météo temps couvert et pluvieux
sur tout a failli métal peuvent tomber
le très doux mais il faut s'attendre à
une tempête sur la manche et en mer du
nord de la neige au dessus de 2000
mètres enfin fin la porte il n'y a pas
de danger moral en cette soirée spéciale
recommande d'ailleurs pas
particulièrement la veillée de noël
d'antenne 2 à partir de 23h30 qui aura
lieu en l'église saint-séverin quelque
part présenté par catherine lara et
puisque les dernières pensées pour nos
camarades de télédiffusion de france qui
se trouve au 9e étage la rue cognacq-jay
et qui vont veiller tard dans la nuit au
travail pour que vous puissiez recevoir
vos émissions de télé 0 et bien c'est
avec l'école à l'essaimage qui nous sont
données par notre équipe un joueur que
nous refermer son journal betty dureau
et toute l'équipe d'antenne 2 vous
renouvelle leurs meilleurs souhaits
bonne soirée de noël et à demain 20
heures
manu
ma seconde